The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
DAVID HARDT: Good morning,
everyone here in Cambridge,
and happy holidays to
you guys in Singapore.
What's the holiday?
I had it on my PDA, but
I've forgotten what it is.
Let's see if I can tell you.
Labor Day, it's Labor
Day in Singapore.
OK?
Somebody was asking me when
Labor Day is in the US,
and you think of
labor, of course,
it means something
different than this.
But do you think of
labor as something
that's kind of onerous and
something you don't always
look forward to doing.
And that's, for an
academic at least,
that's September, when you
have to go back to work.
So it's in September in the US.
OK.
Excuse me.
My voice is shot, so you may be
lucky, and I may finish early.
It's never happened
before but might today.
What I've been asked
to talk about today
is this concept
of using feedback
to improve the statistical
performance of a process,
and it's got this title,
Cycle to Cycle Control.
Just a little caveat,
this whole lecture
and the material behind it
and two research projects
that came out of it were spawned
about eight or nine years ago,
when I was preparing a
lecture for this class,
pre-internet transmission,
that kind of stuff.
And I thought, gee, what
would happen if we--
we used to do a lot of stuff on
feedback control in the class
but for a different reason.
I said, how about if we
applied it here and came up
with this idea of
cycle to cycle control.
One of the problems was,
of course, I found out
that it was old material.
It was actually
hidden in textbooks.
It was treated in
a different way.
So this is, let's just
say, a different spin
on a somewhat well-known
topic but usually
under the heading of advanced
material on the use of feedback
control in the context of a
statistical process control
problem.
Now, I'm going to go through
a couple of slides which
were from day one of the
class, and to emphasize,
I think what we said back then
is that, in effect, there's
always feedback going on.
Now, most of the stuff we've
done in the class so far on SPC
and designed experiments has
been, in the classical feedback
control sense, open loop.
You do something, you
record what happens,
but there's no necessarily
algorithmic approach to saying,
OK, what if it's not right?
I don't what Professor
Bohning said about SPC,
but SPC doesn't
necessarily tell you
what actions to do to
correct what's wrong.
What it does is it
tells you the process
is not following the model, the
statistical model that you had.
And are designed experiments and
process optimization is indeed
falls into the larger context
of open-loop optimization.
How can I run a process in
effect unattended open loop
and still have it be robust
to things trying to deter it
from its proper course?
We talked at the
beginning of the term
about this idea of the general
process control problem,
and I'm sure you remember
like it was yesterday
that I referred to this process
control loop is the Holy Grail.
Boy, if we could do that,
all this other stuff
wouldn't matter.
Because it would mean that
I would have in some way
the ability to interact with
a process and say here's
what I want.
Here's a dimension that I want.
Maybe here's a variability
that I can tolerate.
Here's a property strength or a
reactivity or something I want.
If I simply measure it and
apply correctly feedback control
principles, compare the two,
somehow with the magic control
algorithm, everything
will be fine.
And feedback control,
if it's successful,
always seeks to make the
difference between those two
close to zero and as
quickly as possible.
So the concept of
process output control
or controlling the product
geometry and properties
was put forward.
And at the time, we probably
said, but it doesn't work,
or it can't happen,
or it's very rare.
So what motivates this
particular concept is the idea
that this is indeed
very hard to do,
and it's very hard to
do for two reasons.
One is you seldom can find out
what's wrong with the product,
until it's too late.
When you think about
most of the processes--
there are a few exceptions
to this-- but most processes,
semiconductor is
a great example,
but every kind of mechanical
and thermal process around,
basically you have to make
something, put it down,
oh, we're done.
OK.
Let's measure it.
Did it fit?
Is it the right shape?
Does it have the
right properties?
And it's too late.
So if it's wrong,
what do you do?
OK?
So what do you do?
If you run the process, you pick
up the product, you measure it,
it's not right.
What do you do?
It's not a rhetorical question.
It's a question.
What do I do?
AUDIENCE: Throw it away.
Or redo your work.
DAVID HARDT: Throw it away.
Rework it.
And that's what we do now right.
You got pass/fail, throw it
away if it's a low value added.
If it's a high
value added thing,
like an airplane or
something like that, then
you do rework it.
Richard, what else?
AUDIENCE: Well, if the
[INAUDIBLE] is big enough,
or the production
is big enough, you
could try to adjust
your process.
For example, when you have
a C and C turning process,
you could try to
make adjustments
for the true position.
DAVID HARDT: Yep.
Oh, yeah.
So you can do all
three of those things.
And what we're going
to talk about today
is more towards what Richard
was saying, which is you learn.
You take that as data and say,
oh, something's not right here.
And the question now is we
can always take that data--
and I made it sound black
or white-- it's a good part
or it's a bad part.
But indeed, as you know, is it--
from the concept of
process capability,
is it falling where
I expected it to?
Is it falling outside there
or is it tending there--
to there?
And how quickly
do I take action?
Now, SPC in general is
about-- you, in effect,
sit back, measure the
statistical performance
of the process and say, OK,
is this matching my model?
If it's not, pull the cord.
Make some changes.
Something's wrong.
Investigate.
What we're going to talk about
today is the extreme of that,
which is to say every single
part that comes out we will
assume should be correct.
But it will be off
by some amount--
based on that error,
on a production cycle
to cycle basis.
Every time we make
something, we'll measure it.
Every time we measure it, we'll
compare it to the target value.
And if it's wrong, we'll
make an adjustment.
Now, I can guarantee you
there are a number of papers--
many papers, probably
thousands-- hundreds,
I should say--
and many textbooks that will
tell you, that's crazy talk.
It's nuts-- should never do
that, because you'll never
you'll get it better.
Now, based on what you know so
far about statistical processes
and the nature of these
techniques that we've done,
as well as a little bit
on physical processes,
why would you imagine
the statistics community
in particular would
have that attitude
towards this approach of what
we call constant adjustment?
Can you think why
that's not a good idea?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Instead of some
underlying median [INAUDIBLE]
process, and you continuously
keep changing the mean,
then you're
continuously changing
the balance of the median.
So unless it is
statistically significant
outside some bounds, I
guess they would object
to making changes based
on something that's
the normal expected means,
DAVID HARDT: OK.
Yeah, yeah.
Richard-- same thing?
Yeah, that's basically right.
I'm going to state it a
little bit differently.
Everything could be
fine, and your process
is following a nice
normal distribution,
and here's your target--
basically says you will
always have an error.
It will always be wrong.
You'll always be
adjusting the process.
It's the concept of a
dog chasing its tail.
How can that possibly
make it better?
So they just say, don't do it.
And they're actually
studies out there.
There's a wonderful
study that was
done by a professor at
Harvard Business School on--
I've forgotten what the--
do you know this one?
The [INAUDIBLE]?
I think it was a big basic
material, basic mineral
processing plant, one of
these huge things with lots
of different set points.
And the operators had
control over this thing,
and they were always
looking at things.
And they could type
the new numbers
and change the change the
set points in the plant,
and that sort of
thing, and they all
had their idea of how
they could make it better.
And he had this hypothesis that
they were chasing their tail.
They were looking
at these things,
and they were always
adjusting the process.
So one day, with the
concurrence of the management,
from the operator's
point of view,
everything was still the
same, but they disconnected it
so that the operators
were making changes
to all the set points in
the machines-- nothing
was actually changing.
And guess what happened.
It got better.
The variance went down.
And so that kind of
circumstantial stuff says,
OK, it is crazy talk.
Why should I bother to do that?
But-- there's an important
but here-- is that,
if that's all the
information you have--
if your idea is, OK, based on
the error, make an adjustment,
if you have any schooling
in feedback control,
you know that just closing
the loop is not success.
In fact, closing the
loop, as I was once
chastised by one
of my professors--
all that guarantees is that you
can take a nice stable process
and eventually make
it go unstable.
But you have to close
the loop with a knowledge
of what's going on and
a knowledge of what
the limits are.
And in the end, what that
means is you've got--
if you're going to have an
operator making adjustments
to the process based
on measurements,
they should have some basis--
for a basis for that.
So that's what this
whole thing is about is,
what is that basis, and
how good could it be?
OK.
OK, wake up now.
All right.
And just to tie this back
in with what we talked about
in the beginning, if you look
at this variability equation--
which, I don't know how
much you've used that during
the term-- it's not important--
but the whole idea is that what
we'd like to do is
change the variability,
reduce the variability
of a process,
and we'd like to do it--
SPC does it by reducing
the disturbance,
design experiments does it
reducing the sensitivity,
and feedback control does it by
trying to offset the problems.
So if there is something
that's causing a mean shift,
you want to push it back
by making an offset change,
and that's all that
this is relating to.
And so in effect, we
get to the third level
of this process control
hierarchy that--
talked about on day 1, which
is-- the first one is basically
good housekeeping, standard
operating procedures,
statistical analysis,
and identification
of whether everything
is in a state
of stationary
statistical control.
Second one is
reducing sensitivity
or increasing robustness.
That's the whole
designed experiment area.
And then finally--
this gets it as good
as it can be without
active manipulation--
and then finally, we actively
manipulate and see what we do.
So I do think I've come
to firmly believe--
even though I came
to this whole thing
from a feedback control can
solve any problem in the world
point of view--
this is the last thing you do
after you've tried these far
cheaper, far more robust,
and far more, in some ways,
in depth knowledge of
the process approaches.
OK, so I have to take
a moment to just review
feedback control.
How many of you guys have had
a feedback control course?
OK.
Hayden, you've never
had a feedback control--
AUDIENCE: Yes.
DAVID HARDT: OK.
If the TA hasn't had the
course, we're in trouble.
And we often use this generic
feedback control regulator
approach, and I want
to do this because I'm
going to use a little
bit of terminology.
This is stuff we've
already used in the class,
but I want to look at a
little bit differently.
So let me just define
the terms here.
Whoops-- this box right here--
that's the process.
That's the
manufacturing process.
That's the machine, the
material, all that other stuff
we talked about.
And the input to that is
something that I can change--
temperature, pressure,
a feed, a time--
something like that.
The output of the process is
the output of the process.
It's what we care about.
Actually, I'm going to put the
output of the process over here
for the moment.
The key thing is
that the process--
there are two things
that make the process not
always do the same thing.
In other words, if I hold the
inputs the same all the time,
the output still varies.
We know that.
We know that from SPC. You know
it from data that you've taken.
Where is that other
thing coming from?
Well, in a control system
sense, one of the sources
is the disturbance.
We just kind of think of it
as an external factor, this D1
or D2.
The classic example of
that is a flight control,
altitude, autopilot.
What's a good disturbance
to an autopilot?
Well, a wind current
or something like that
is external to the machine.
It causes it to change and
causes the output of the flight
control system to change.
The purpose of the
controller in that case,
and the purpose of the
controller primarily
for manufacturing, is to
minimize the effective these
disturbances.
You'd like to make it look
like they aren't there so
that you're flying the plane,
and wind's blowing up and down,
and it still keeps going level.
You're machining
something, and the material
gets harder or softer.
You just keep
going the same way.
You're etching something,
and maybe your solution
is losing strength, but
it still etches enough--
all those sorts of things.
That's a standard way of
modeling things in control,
and that's the way we'll
do it for this approach.
In fact, what happens more often
than not in manufacturing--
it's captured by this
crazy little arrow here,
the dark one, which
basically says, yeah,
well, this input-output
relationship
between the settings
on the machine
and the output of the material
is, in fact, never a constant.
We're always putting
in different material.
The machine is
changing over time.
This is all the stuff we
talked about in the first days.
So in fact, we have two
types of disturbances--
these external ones and
these internal ones.
The problem is that, from
a control system theory
point of view, the external ones
are easy to model and analyze.
The internal ones are very
uneasy to model and analyze.
So we will actually
look more at this one,
even though we'll pretend that
we're looking at both of these.
So again, the purpose
of the control system
is to make this output
quantity stay exactly
in line with what the
input quantity is,
which, of course, would be some
sort of a desired dimension--
something like that.
Again, if any of you have
studied control systems
in any advanced way, we
have this-- one aspect
of control systems is
called stochastic control
systems, which is where the
control theory actually assumes
that the variables that you're
controlling and other things
have some randomness
associated with it.
Most control is done, of course,
for deterministic quantities,
but in fact, most things
have these random components.
And when you do that,
you find that what
you're taught on that is
that, well, if I use feedback,
I can minimize mean
shifts in the process,
or mean shifts in
the disturbance.
And I can often reduce
so-called dynamic disturbances.
If things are changing
from time to time,
I should be able
to reduce those.
So if I translate
that into the lexicon
of this class, that kind
of means-- well, look here.
Here's a distribution.
Let me-- I'm drawing too
many lines here, hang on.
I can't-- This
distribution on the left--
well, first of all, let me point
out what I tried to draw here.
Here you see this is your
process capability window.
That's where you want to be.
So ideally, we're
centered on that, and well
within the bounds of that.
Imagine you have a process
that's operating over here.
So it's obviously got
terrible process capability.
The mean is way
over here, and even
if I were to send it
within the target window,
it would probably
be outside that,
and I'd have a low
process capability.
So wouldn't it be nice
to have a controller that
can take this
distribution, center it,
and even make it narrower?
Well, there's a suggestion that
feedback control can do that,
because we know we can eliminate
mean errors with feedback
control.
The question is, what
happens with the variance?
And as we thought about this
idea of chasing your tail--
excuse me-- how can I be
measuring a random variable,
particularly an uncorrelated
random variable,
and use that knowledge
to actually reduce
the degree of randomness?
Keep thinking about that.
But we can analyze it,
and then, of course,
the proof of the pudding will
be to actually do an experiment.
Oops-- OK, so what do
we want to look at--
in trying to understand this,
what kind of disturbances
do we expect to see, or how do
we want to model disturbances?
Well, we know so far that,
to capture the process,
we're going to have to model
disturbances as being random.
Our whole premise for
the statistical models
is that the process has some
randomness associated with it.
And then we have things
like unexpected mean shifts,
which, in control lexicon,
we call infrequent stepwise.
And then we might have
things like tool wear
or just degradation of
solutions and things over time,
and so there's a slowly
varying change of the process.
And then, of course, cyclic--
things that are happening
because of shift changes, time
of day, other things like that.
It would be nice to
deal with all those.
For the moment, we're
going to deal primarily
with infrequent stepwise
random disturbances.
There are more
advanced topics on this
that will deal with
these too, but we
won't get into those today.
OK, so cycle-to-cycle
control is simply
defined as doing the best
you can with this situation
that we have now.
So the ideal thing is to have
a full measure of how you're
doing on your production.
You can always make
that measurement
after the cycle of
production has finished.
Maybe an injection
molding machine
is a good model for
this, or something
that happens kind of
quick, or a metal stamping
operation or high-speed forging
operation-- any of these things
where you can't get in
there with your gauge
while it's happening,
unless you're crazy.
And even if you did, you
wouldn't-- it wouldn't tell you
what you wanted to know.
Like an injection molded part--
until it's popped out-- in
fact, until it's cooled off,
you don't know how you did.
So it's finally
there, you measure it,
and then you say, oh, I
have to make a change.
Can I make a change?
And most machines will allow
you to make a change somewhere.
You did your
designed experiments,
and the whole idea
of that was to say,
what are the significant inputs
to change significantly--
have a significant
change in the output?
So we find out what
those significant ones
are and try to match them.
So if the dimension
is wrong, you say,
OK, here's what I want
to adjust to change it.
Now, the key thing is this--
or think of it this way.
Take injection molding,
because I'll give you
some data on that in a moment.
You set it up.
You run a part.
You take it onto the bench.
You measure it.
You say, it's not right.
How soon can I make a change
in the process to improve it?
Next cycle-- so before I say go
again, I make a little change.
I increase the hold time,
I decrease the pressure--
something like that.
Then I say, go.
And I keep doing that, and
it's cycle to cycle the cycle.
But within each cycle, when
I say change the whole time
or I say change the pressure,
during the actual cycle
of injection-- of melding,
and injecting, and cooling
the material, nothing changes.
So from the injection molding
machine process point of view,
it's still this
fixed input process.
So that's the important thing.
The dynamics occurs between the
cycles, not during the cycles.
So what this allows
us to do is treat this
as a very simple digital control
system, or discrete control
system.
So in discrete control
theory concepts,
things only happen in an
instantaneous period in time.
Nothing happens in between.
So we've got a nice
match between the theory
and what's actually happening.
And so we execute this
loop once every cycle.
Now, you may be saying, jeez,
do we have to measure it
after every cycle?
What about every 10th cycle?
Maybe it's going to
take too much time
to make the measurement and slow
the process down, and so on.
Fine-- we can put
those multipliers in.
But the fastest we could ever
do it would be one cycle--
one measurement per cycle.
Well, this is where
we found out that we
had reinvented the wheel--
or uninvented the wheel,
or something like that.
Within the
semiconductor industry,
there's this concept
of run-by-run control,
where you've got a recipe,
you run the process,
you make a measurement,
you say it's not right--
let's change the recipe--
that sort of thing.
It's given the title
run-by-run control.
And I think even, if you look
in the text on Montgomery--
and I don't remember
what chapter
it's in-- there's
something in there about--
forgot the term he used--
I think he calls it
feedback control.
But there is some
discussion of this.
And there are some
larger theoretical tracks
around that talk about the
concept of a discrete control
system like this.
So what is it we're
really trying to do?
Well, to use, again, the
terminology of the class,
we would like to reduce
the expected loss function
or increase a measure of process
capability with feedback.
So ultimately, as I said, if
our goal is to go, say, from--
if we have a target that looks
like that and we have a process
that's over here
somewhere-- oops--
it's not very
[INAUDIBLE] looking.
If we can make the process
look more like that,
we will have increased
our process capability
or decreased our process--
our expected loss.
And we can think of that,
again, with our two major goals.
One is to reduce mean
shift to zero, if possible,
and decrease the variance.
Now, this is a bit of a--
I can't think of the word
I'm trying to come up with.
Anyway, it's-- we're looking
to the future of what's going
to happen with the results here.
What if I have a process
that's over here,
and I'm able to recenter it
without reducing the variance?
Is that a good thing?
Yeah.
OK.
What if I have a process
over here, and all I can do
is recenter it--
I can recenter it,
but at the cost
of increasing the variance?
Is that a good thing?
Well, that sort of depends.
I didn't tell you how much
I'm going to increase it.
If I increase it
by a factor of 10,
you'd probably say it's no good.
And what if I could move it
over here, center the process,
and reduce the variance
at the same time?
Of course-- why
wouldn't that be great?
So we're going to think
of those as objectives.
Now, we have to go through this
to understand the derivation.
And the punch line that I'm
going to come to is, hey,
we can actually do
two of those three.
I'm going to show you that
we can send her this--
guarantee it--
I love that-- seldom
get to say that.
But we can guarantee
that we can it,
virtually under
any circumstance.
And we can even tell you how
long it will take to center it,
how many cycles--
can always do that.
And then there'll
be two extremes.
In one extreme, I can
see it, but I will always
increase the variance--
but by a well-established,
bounded amount.
So it's not going to be one
day 20 times, another day
two times-- that sort of thing.
It'll tell you exactly
how much it is.
In the other case-- the
better one, of course--
I can center it and
reduce the variance.
Now, the naysayers that
we talked about earlier,
who would say, oh, don't
adjust the process--
it'll only get worse--
we're right, in the
sense that, if I
just the process and center
the mean, but increase
the variance, by one
measure of goodness,
things have gotten worse.
It's got more variability.
And we can see,
more heuristically
than theoretically, why that,
in fact, has to be true.
But again, if it's bounded
and we know what's going on,
maybe it's better.
Maybe it's a lot better.
OK, so how do we
actually get to use this?
And I'm going to go
through this real quickly,
because again, if
you guys have seen
feedback control in its
basics, you probably
did it for continuous systems,
and that doesn't really
give you that much
insight into what we're
going to be doing here.
And there's some-- a
couple derivations here,
which I will just zip
through and assume,
if you're interested, you can
back and look at the notes.
Oh yeah, before I forget--
because I don't want to
wait until the punch line
at the end--
there are two papers that
I've put on the website that
basically recite what
we're talking about--
what I'm talking about here--
paper that George Su and I
authored several years back.
Well, George did his master's
thesis on this whole topic.
He was a 2830 student the year
I kind of made up this lecture.
Actually, it was a whole
section of the class back then.
And he said, hey, that
would be interesting.
Can I do a master's
thesis on it?
I said yes, and he
did, and that's--
a lot of the results I'm
going to talk about today
are on that.
And then we had a
particular problem in our--
oh, great-- I just erased it.
Well, there's a
second paper that's
on there that Adam [INAUDIBLE]
did with me based on his PhD.
And Adam was also a
student in the class, also
a TA in the class, and
he wanted to say, well,
what happens if I have a
really big complicated process?
Instead of having one
input and one output,
maybe it had 1,000 inputs
and 1,000 outputs--
because we happened to have
one in our lab that fit that.
And he said, maybe we can
make it work for this.
So he did the extension to that.
And that paper is
very brief version
of what happens when
you try to extend it
beyond what I've done.
But it all requires that
we go through a little bit
of the theory.
So what am I trying to
represent with this diagram?
I'll give you guys a test
of your control background.
What is this?
Richard--
AUDIENCE: Step response?
DAVID HARDT: Yeah.
This is a classical,
highly simplified example
of a-- the simplest dynamic
system you can have.
And in the lexicon of
our class here, I've
made a step change to an input.
I instantaneously change the
pressure, temperature, feed--
something like that.
And what's the output do?
Well, in real systems, they
don't change instantaneously.
They have dynamics.
And the simplest dynamics
would be something
like this, a simple lag.
This would be a
first-order linear system,
and it takes four time
constants to settle out.
And so there's an
important number here,
which is what I'll call
the process time constant.
How long does it
take the process
to reach a steady state after
you've made a change to it?
That's going to become an
important number for us.
And then we have
the disturbance,
which would be our randomized
and that sort of thing.
But why do I care about
this steady state number?
Why do I put this number
four times the time
constant of there.
Why do you think--
given where we're going?
We're only going to look at
the process after it's done.
We're only going to make a
change between the processes.
I'm only going to
look at the output.
Think of it, we're going to
talk about a sampler in just
a second.
Sampler is a mathematical
concept, in effect,
based on a delta function
that says, here's
a continuous number.
I'm going to sample it and look
at it for an infinitesimally
small period of time.
So I'm going to do
this to the output.
So I'm going to make
a change, and then I'm
going to sample the output.
When do I want to
sample the output?
AUDIENCE: After it's stabilized.
DAVID HARDT: After
it's stabilized--
all right, so conceptually, if
I have a process that has this
speed to it, and I make sure
I always sample it after
it's reached this steady state--
after a stepwise change--
what does the process look
like, from an input-output point
of view?
Constant input gives
me a constant output.
I don't see any dynamics.
I don't see any of
this stuff in between.
And can you see that
then, if I looked
at a lot of different inputs--
let the output all go to steady
state, looked at all the sample
ones--
I basically have a bunch of
inputs, a bunch of outputs.
And what would be the simplest
relationship between those two?
You just did your
designed experiments.
What's the simplest
relationship that you
could have between a single
input, a single output?
Yeah-- straight
line, linear fit.
And that's a great
first place for us
to start with this model.
So the nice thing is, with
the cycle-to-cycle control,
I can take a process
that could be, in fact,
a lot more complicated by this--
than this, and just say, sorry.
I can reduce it down to--
I hope it's my next slide.
I hope this thing will work.
I'm going to skip
through all this.
This diagram says that what's,
in fact, maybe happening
with the processes that I make
a change at a particular time.
It comes up to steady state,
but I sample it here, here,
here, and here.
And all that mess in between I'm
unaware of, I don't care about.
And what I can do now is
reduce the whole process down
to a single number.
The nice thing is--
I don't need to go
into this right now--
I don't even need to
worry about the offset.
You think of a straight
line fit-- you've
got the slope and the offset.
In the approach that we take
here with cycle to cycle,
I don't even care
about the offset.
In run-by-run they
do, but it turns out
it comes out in the wash anyway.
So now all I need to know about
the process is an input-output
relationship between--
but it's discrete.
It's between a discrete
input at and instant
in time and a discrete output.
So that is a valid model
of our process now.
The only thing
that's questionable
is, what's this number,
and is it a constant?
In other words, if I
run the process today,
is it one number?
Is it another number?
And of course, as you know, we
would do a test for linearity,
or maybe it should
be-- maybe it would
be better modeled as quadratic
and other stuff like that.
Without going into
it, and again,
invoking the linearization
properties of a good control
system, it doesn't matter.
As long as we have a
pretty good estimate of it
and as long as it's not
rapidly changing, we're OK.
OK.
So here's,
ultimately, our model.
We have the process.
We have some
process uncertainty,
and we're going to bring that
in as a purely additive number--
because the model I just showed
you was a deterministic model.
There was no randomness
in it, so it obviously
doesn't capture
what we care about.
And I'm going to sample
that output compare it
to what I want, and that'll be
my cycle-to-cycle controller.
Now, when you get into
discrete control systems,
one of the things that
you can easily model
is the idea of a pure delay.
Obviously, if I got something
that happens a given cycle,
and nothing--
I don't do anything until the
next cycle of time happens,
I can have the concept
of a pure delay
as well-- something
happens here,
but there's no reaction
until here, or here, or here.
And the theory of
discrete control systems
allows you to deal with
delays very nicely.
And we have three kinds of
delays in any control system,
but certainly happened here.
One is measurement delay.
Part comes off-- takes me
some time to measure it.
Because of that
measurement delay,
there's no way that I
can make an adjustment
before the next cycle.
So I already have a
delay based on that.
There's controller delay.
Well, of course, if we're using
fast computers and that sort
of thing, that can
be made very small,
but it does take some time.
And if it's an operator, a human
being measuring it and then
doing a little bit of
pencil work on a path,
there's a delay
associated with that.
And then there's
a process delay.
When can I make the machine?
When is the machine next
available to be changed?
So given all three
of these, what
do you think-- for
this model, what
do you think the
correct model of delay
is for this approach
to process control?
Now, let me preface this
with one other comment.
We have a basic unit
of time here now?
Other than zero, what's
the shortest time interval
that's possible that
exists in this approach
to the whole feedback
control thing?
The fastest I can do something--
AUDIENCE: One cycle--
DAVID HARDT: One cycle--
yeah-- one cycle, right?
Because nothing
exists between cycles.
When something happens, the next
chance I can do something on
is a cycle.
So this is all kind
of time-independent.
In terms of real time, it's
just based on the cycle
time of the process.
So given this, go back
to that other question.
There are delays involved in
all discrete control system.
There are delays in
this control system.
How do you think we should model
the delays of a manufacturing
process for this context
of cycle-to-cycle control?
I'll give you the
thought experiment.
Run the injection
molding machine.
Put the part on the bench.
Measure the part.
Figure out the next control
cycle based on the algorithm
I'm going to come up with.
Adjust the machine.
Push the button.
Run the machine again.
That's the delay structure.
How would you model that delay?
Or how many delays or how
many machine cycles do I need
to delay the process, minimum?
One?
1/2?
1/10?
10?
I know I'm not making
myself clear here.
I can see that.
Richard--
AUDIENCE: Well, the
discrete points of time,
where you're looking
at your process
that you're actually modeling,
I probably arrived when
your part comes out, kind of.
So you should probably
have a delay of one cycle.
DAVID HARDT: Exactly, exactly--
if I can measure quickly, make
a decision quickly, and be
ready to adjust the
machine before it's time
to push the button, then I have
built in a one-cycle delay.
The best I could ever do is--
and this is how you capture
in the theory, at least.
The whole idea of
cycle-to-cycle control
is I make a measurement.
The next chance I have to
intervene on the process
is one cycle later.
So you build in a
one-cycle delay.
OK, why does this
make a big difference?
Well, in looking at discrete
time control theory,
the whole concept
of a delay operator
is the whole basis for it.
Now, if you dig into
your deep dark pasts
on the control
system theory, you
may have remembered something
called the Laplace transform,
Laplace operator, and all
that other business, which
was a way of algebraically
describing time differential
equations.
What you have with a
discrete control system
is time difference
equations, things
are just sums of
inputs and outputs
at different intervals of time.
There's an equivalent
to that operator, which
is called the z transform.
And you're not going to
do z transforms here,
much as I'd love to,
but basically it's
an operator that says, if I--
I transform everything
into this z domain,
and now the concept of an
advance in time by one time
step can be done by
having-- by pre-multiplying
by this operator
z with an exponent
that's a number of steps
ahead you want to do.
If I want to have a delay, then
I just put a negative exponent
up here.
And so for example, if I
think of this concept of--
here's the terminology
is, here's the output y
at instant of time i.
There's no continuous
variable t.
It's the sample i, if you will.
If I multiply that number
by z to the plus 1, that's
the same as saying, oh, you
mean y one time step ahead?
And if I multiply
it by z squared,
it's two time steps ahead.
And more relevant to what
we're doing here, if I say,
OK, here's an output
at the current time i,
if I pre-multiply it by this
operator z to the minus 1,
I'm really saying let's look
at it one time step behind.
So when we look at
our process model,
we have to modify it a
little bit we say, OK, we
can do this anywhere
in the loop we want,
but we decided to do it here
because it's the easiest.
When I make a
change to the input,
conceptually, I
don't get to see what
happens to that until
the cycle is over
and I'm ready to
do the next cycle.
So we're going to
model the whole thing
not as a simple gain, but as--
it's got messed up in
this-- but as this.
Or in other words,
we're going to say
that the current output is
equal to the prior input
times that gain.
And this may seem
pretty trivial to you,
but this is the basis
of the whole thing.
It's very simple from a discrete
control system point of view,
but the mere fact
that you say, yeah,
the input leads to the output--
but a time step later is
what makes the whole thing--
it's the part that
makes it not work,
if you don't know
what you're doing,
and it's the part
you have to analyze
to be sure what is going on.
OK, so for the moment,
we've modeled the process.
It's a pure gain with a one
time step one-cycle delay.
Here's some data from
a process that's--
I think this is probably under
a state of statistical control.
And you know that these
lines in between here--
this is done on Excel--
the lines in between there
don't exist.
It's dots here.
Here's a measurement, there's
a measurement-- so on.
They're just there to
let you see it better.
So that's the output
of our real process.
Well, how does the model
I just came up with
reflect this in any way?
Of course, it doesn't.
I haven't included
the randomness at all.
So what we have to do is
add in some randomness,
then do our sampling,
and then see
if we get something
that looks like this.
So again, we have to
come up with a model that
fits what we observe in real
life-- what I just showed--
you and also is amenable
to our control theory.
So again, as I said, here's--
we're still continuous here now.
This is before we've
done the sampling.
We've got this continuous
random variable, d of t.
It's always there.
It's always changing.
Then we sample at our--
once every cycle, and we
get our discrete variable.
Now it should include
a random component.
That's not exactly
what it should say.
Well, that's jumping ahead,
but let's go ahead and do that.
So now, in our cycle-to-cycle
control system,
we're going to add into it
basically a sequence of numbers
that follows a stationary
normal distribution function.
Well, that's no big deal.
That's what you've been
doing all along the term,
so that's-- that
shouldn't be a problem.
This is just a little
bit of a connection
between continuous theory
and the discrete theory.
A continuous or random
number is, in fact, that.
If you go back to our
early stuff on statistics,
this is really where
we started from.
But there's this number
that's changing continuously,
and it's never the same
number at any time,
and it's following a
Gaussian distribution,
and it's stationary-- or
a normal distribution,
I should say.
At any instant in time, there
is no correlation, meaning,
if I sample this
distribution right now
and I get a particular
number, that
gives absolutely no
information about what's
going to happen next.
It does allow me eventually,
with enough data,
to say what the distribution
is, but it tells me
nothing about what's
going to happen next.
So it's totally uncorrelated.
And if we sample
that process, then
we get what we've used
throughout the term,
is this normal
identically distributed
independent random sequence.
Had-- do any of you use NIDI?
You talked about the acronym?
AUDIENCE: We've used IIND, and--
DAVID HARDT: OK, all the other--
AUDIENCE: Other permutations--
DAVID HARDT: OK.
Normal identically
distributed independence--
so it means a stationary random
variable with no correlation
from time to time.
All right, here's the algebra.
And it's the key
to the whole thing,
but I won't go through
it, except to say
that, if you remember your
block diagram algebra,
there's a clear algebra
that happens here.
And we'll just take
the first step here.
The output y sub i-- what
this diagram means is that
the output y sub i going
this way is equal to--
that's a summation there--
I should have put
out there-- it's
equal to d sub i plus
the output of this box.
And the output of this
box is kp times u sub i
delayed by one time step.
So that's all of that
equation means right there.
Then we solve backwards here.
We say, OK, well, there's
this value right here--
the input to that happens to
be equal to the controller
gain times the difference of
the reference and our feedback.
You put it all together, and
this is the equation for this--
the output of the controller.
And then here's the
important thing.
If I now say, all
right, I'm going
to make the input my command--
think of it as a dimension or
something for what we're doing
here-- a constant value--
10 inches-- never
going to change.
And you can think
of it as a constant.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Back up.
I'm going to do that too.
For the moment, let's say
that the disturbance is not
random-- it's just
a constant value.
I'm going to use the term mu,
but it's a constant value.
If I do that, and put
it into this equation,
and solve for y sub i,
and I let time go forever,
so it's now steady state, if
you go through the algebra, what
you get is that the steady
state value of the output
is equal to these two
quantities right here.
It's the disturbance
divided by this quantity,
and it's the reference
multiplied by that quantity.
OK-- big deal.
But here's the big deal.
Here's the output
value in steady state.
Here's the disturbance.
What do I want that
quantity to be,
if this is a good
control system?
And for the moment, imagine
that my reference is zero.
Conceptually, that's
an important thing.
Imagine that my
reference is zero,
so the ideal output of
the process is zero.
Now this says that the ratio
of the output in steady
state to the disturbance,
which is finite--
some constant value--
is this quantity.
What would I like
this quantity to be?
How about zero?
Disturbances are bad.
If this number is
anything but zero,
then I am not rejecting
my disturbance.
Let's jump ahead to say,
if I can't make this zero,
I can't center
this distribution,
because this shift
is indeed that--
its mean shift.
How can I make
this zero, Can't--
can I?
How do I make this
quantity zero?
There it is right there.
How do I make that
quantity zero?
I could do that.
If I can make it an infinite
gain, it would be zero--
tough thing to do.
So kind of saying,
it would be easy,
we're not going to
be able to do it.
And this means that I
won't be able to do this,
and the naysayers were right,
and all that sort of thing.
But fortunately,
you'll see in a moment,
there is a way we can do it.
And maybe you saw this in your
control system things as well.
Conceptually, all
I need is this game
to be equal infinity when
things are in steady state.
That's one way to think of it.
The other way to think of it is,
if you did your control systems
theory, it said,
steady state area
equals zero-- that means I
want an integral controller.
And there's theoretical
reasons for that.
So what we can do, instead of
using a simple controller--
I should back up here.
What I did in here is I picked
our controller, was simply
to say that the controller
was, if there's an error,
make a purely proportional
change in the set points.
Now I'm going to say let's get
a little bit more sophisticated.
Let's do an integral controller.
And an integral controller
in discrete terms
is simply a running
sum of the errors.
If you remember back to
Calculus 101, calculus--
typically, when you
drive the integration,
you start off with a
summation, and then
make the summation interval
smaller and smaller
until it becomes continuous.
Now we break it
back the other way
and say, OK, the best we can do
for a discrete time integrator
is to sum up errors.
So this is my new controller.
It simply says the
output at any time,
how I'm going to change the
machine is the sum of all
the prior errors.
Again, I can turn this
into recursive form.
So you just say the next
output is the prior output
plus the next error.
And then I can do the z
transform business on it.
It comes out like this.
And this is where
it gets useful.
Now my controller, instead
of being a simple gain,
looks like this--
the z over z minus 1,
which is describing
this equation.
And I can do the algebra of
this and see what happens.
So I follow the same
block diagram algebra,
and the nice thing now
is that z is simply
a multiplier, so I can treat
it like any other quantity.
If I do that and I
go through all this--
so these z's cancel out.
I write the equation
for the disturbance.
I'm assuming that
r is equal to zero,
so this is zero over here.
Go through the block diagram
algebra, get down to here,
and now a couple of things
are kind of interesting.
But what I can say is
that steady state--
we know that all of the y's
in the system are the same.
Everything's settled out.
And I come down here and say
that, because this disturbance
is a constant, these
two things are the same.
The disturbance at time
20,000 and time 20,000 plus 1
are the same, because
it's a constant.
And when you come down
here, you find out
that this quantity's
equal to zero,
regardless of the loop gain.
In other words,
it doesn't matter
what value I pick for kc.
It's always zero.
So it's just a way
of showing that,
with a simple
integral controller,
I indeed can take a finite
constant disturbance
and completely eliminate
it in steady state--
not instantaneously,
but in steady state.
So now, here's the problem.
Since kc doesn't matter--
that's my controller gain.
That's my design.
Since that doesn't matter--
so must matter to
something, right?
So what value do I pick
for that gain of kc?
What's the effective the
value of this controller
gain on the performance
of this system?
Do you guys remember
from control theory
at all what the effect of a
controller gain is, typically?
Low gain, high gain,
little gain, too high gain,
too low gain--
generally, what happens as you
adjust the controller gain?
AUDIENCE: Speed of the system?
DAVID HARDT: Yeah.
Think of it this way.
Forget about this for a moment.
This controller game
says it's how much I'm
going to adjust the
system based on the error.
If I'm very conservative,
and kc is really small,
and I get, let's say, an error--
a modest error,
I'm going to make
a really modest, timid change.
It's a measure of
timidity, I guess.
I'm going to take a timid
change on the-- over here.
If I'm bold and trusting
my control system--
small error here, large gain--
I make a huge change.
And obviously, a
huge change is going
to get the system moving faster.
So conceptually, heuristically--
however you want to call it--
high gains will generally lead
to faster system response.
Low gains will lead to
slower system response.
Which ones do you think
typically-- but not always--
which ones typically, do you
think, are the most dangerous,
with respect to things like,
as I mentioned earlier,
the property of control
systems known as instability--
high gains or low gains?
High gains, of course-- yeah--
because imagine,
tiny error here.
You're almost there-- huge gain.
You whack the system
with a big thing,
it goes way past where
you wanted it to,
and now you say, oh my
gosh, now it's a large area.
And it keeps coming back and
forth, and next thing you know,
you've got a system
that's unstable.
OK, so to understand
this, you have
to understand discrete
time control theory.
There's some wonderful,
books, and courses
and other things on that.
We don't have time
for that here.
We'll do it heuristically.
We'll do it just
for this system.
Here's what happens.
I'm going to step
through different gains.
Now, I already knew
the theory behind this.
I knew what these numbers needed
to be, but here's what you get.
I got to say one of the thing.
What I'm going to show you is
the product of these two gains.
That's what really matters,
because again, these--
you can collapse
these blocks together,
and it's just this product,
kc kp, that matters--
the so-called loop gain.
If I use a loop gain of
1/2, here's what happens.
If I make a step
change in the input,
it goes 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7--
maybe 8 cycles later it has
reached the final value,
and the error is zero,
just as I expected.
So OK, that's good.
What happens if I
increase the gain?
Should get better--
well, indeed, it does.
Look at this.
If I increase the game to 9/10--
1, 2, maybe 3 cycles--
it's done.
And you notice, this
is really emphasizing
the discrete control
aspect of it.
There's a change, and then who
knows, and then another change,
and then who knows?
So 9/10 is good.
9/10 is good.
Then 1.5/10 should be good.
15/10 should be good.
So I go to 15/10,
and what happens?
Well, it now takes two things.
It took three cycles
to settle here.
Now we're back out to taking
eight cycles to settle,
and I got this oscillation.
So it seems like I
kind of went through--
I was getting better, and
now I'm getting worse.
Just to see what happens, since
this is a simulation anyway,
let's set the loop
gain equal to 2.
And what happens?
The system indeed is now what
we call marginally stable.
And I don't have it on here,
but if I set it to 2.001,
it starts to diverge.
Here's the cool thing.
If I set that equal
to 1, how long
does it take to get
to the correct value?
One time step-- and this is
actually a pretty well-known
concept in discrete
time control systems--
that, if you can magically
find exactly the right gain
so that the loop
gain is equal to 1,
you indeed can get exactly
there in one time step.
So this is our goal.
And it says that the best
control system I could have now
would take a mean
offset like this
and take it to zero
error in one time step.
So this is probably the right
controller for us to use.
It also tells us that,
if I'm too aggressive
and I use a gain--
a loop gain of 2,
then think of the operators
now at the cement plant
that I was talking about.
And they were turning the
knob a little bit too far,
and so they were maybe here or
here, and making things worse.
Or they were here and
they were being too timid,
and it really didn't have any
effect over the time frame
that they were talking about.
If you knew what your process
gains were and you knew where
to set this, you
can always guarantee
that you got the maximum effect
in the minimum amount of time.
Also, the other thing
is the operators
were not using this
control algorithm.
They were using that
control algorithm,
so it would never
get to zero error.
So with a fairly
large gap in coverage
here, what I'm
purporting to show you
is that, if I have a random--
if I have an output-- a process
whose output looks like this,
and I apply this simple
discrete time controller--
which means I measure, adjust,
but adjust according to this
algorithm here,
which basically is--
this is something I think it's
important-- which basically
says, OK, I'm the operator.
I have to make an
adjustment to the process.
Here's the adjustment
I'm going to make.
And the adjustment I'm going
to make is whatever it was
the last time plus this
controller gain-- which,
you're going to
tell me what it is--
times the current error--
little bit different than what
it might have been otherwise.
You can also notice
that, if I bring
this over to the other side,
what it's really telling
the operator is the
increment in the adjustment
should be proportional
to the air, not
the absolute value of it.
But anyway, you implement
that controller.
And what that says
is that, if I have
a random output on my
process stationary--
in a state of stationary
statistical control,
but offset from
here, it tells me
that at least the
mean value here before
will now be the
mean value after.
But the question is,
will the distribution
look like that or will
it look like that?
So we have to look at
the random component.
This gets a lot
harder to do so, I'll
just kind of pop through it--
and again, more heuristically
than mathematically.
Our random model of this thing
is that we have this normally
independent--
identically distributed
independent sequence
for d sub i.
So it's a bunch of numbers
that are coming out,
and they're sampled from
a normal distribution.
If they are totally
independent, what that means
is that these--
there's no way that I
can predict what the next
value of the disturbance
will be-- this d sub i.
If there were, then I could
write an equation that says,
OK, there's some relation
between the current value
and all the prior values.
You often see these so-called
time series equations,
or discrete time equations,
or that sort of thing.
But since there isn't,
then it says, sorry.
It's just not equal
to any function
of any of the prior values.
There's no way to predict
what's going to happen next.
So if I do that, then you can--
I think you can see then that
knowing this doesn't tell me--
doesn't give me a
good idea of how
to adjust it to
take care of what
the next value is going to be.
So there's no way that
knowing the prior value
of the disturbance will
allow me to write an equation
to exactly cancel what
the next one will be.
So again, what I'm
saying is this.
Let's imagine here that
I'm at time interval sub i,
and I have a
disturbance t sub i.
And I measure that,
and I say, ah!
The disturbance at this instant
is the value of d sub i.
What I need to do then is
come up with a-- if you will,
a delta u that's equal to minus
d sub i for the next cycle.
But of course, that's too late.
I can't cancel out
the disturbance
that's already happened.
So I need to know what
d sub i plus 1 is.
And then I could
write this equation,
and I'd cancel it out.
But I can't, because I have no
idea what the next one will be.
But with the controller
that I've written,
there's no way to separate
out these two functions,
so I'm going to do this anyway.
I'm going to do this,
knowing full well
that it's not right,
because it's the only way I
can implement the controller.
And so heuristically,
it can't be good right,
so it must be bad.
Oops-- if you go through
the theory on this,
and even do simulations
and things like that,
indeed, you find out it's bad.
And here's the
measure of badness.
Here's a variance ratio.
This is basically saying I've
taken a random number with
a distribution and with
a certain variance--
and that's sigma squared--
this is before and after.
Let me write that down here.
This is before
and this is after.
This ratio is how much
the control system
has increased or decreased
the variance of the output.
And this is a function
of this loop gain
that we talked
about, this quantity
we'd like to have at 1.
OK, so what does this mean?
Well, if I don't
do any control--
loop gain is zero-- then I
haven't increased the variance
at all, and so it's at 1.
That ratio's at 1.
Let's go out to our favorite
number, which was 1,
because it gives
the best response.
And it means I've increased the
variance ratio to about 2.2.
Or the standard
deviation ratio, I think,
comes out to about 1.5.
So I've taken this width, and
I've increased it by 50%--
nothing I can do about,
nothing I can do about it.
I can run a slower process.
I can say, OK,
I'll take some time
steps to reach steady
state and maybe
bring it down to 1.3, but--
so this is, in fact, a
really good description
of what I was
telling you before.
With this control system,
with this type of noise,
I can take a process
that looks like this,
I can guarantee the [INAUDIBLE]
but I'm going to increase
the variance by some factor,
depending on what I set
the gain at--
probably 50%.
Is that good or is that bad?
Depends-- getting
rid of mean shifts
is a pretty important thing.
If you think about the
philosophy of Six Sigma,
this is actually pretty
good, because Six Sigma--
one starts with
narrow distributions,
allows for mean offsets.
And if we say,
OK, but we'll make
sure you don't get mean
offsets, and you already
have a narrow distribution,
we'll only make it 50% wider.
So I don't want to sell it
too much, but it's half good,
it's half bad.
Richard--
AUDIENCE: But if you can
adjust the loop gain at 0.2,
we would still arrive at
our process mean, right?
DAVID HARDT: Yep.
Yeah, but I'll
show you an example
of why that might
not be a good idea,
when we get to the experiments.
OK, so the conclusion--
cycle-to-cycle control for an
uncorrelated random disturbance
can do what I said.
It takes this
distribution, shifts it,
guarantees that it's
going to be at zero mean,
but it widens the distribution.
Obviously, I've drawn
this so that it still
looks fine and the--
and if I looked at this as
cpk, or expected quality loss,
the way I've drawn it,
this is a winner by a lot.
This has terrible
process capability,
and now this is
really pretty good,
even though it got wider--
because of the mean shift.
However, not all
processes are the same,
and there's a big difference
in a lot of these.
And so what if the
process is not well
described by a normally
identically distributed
independent random variable?
Don't worry about what
that says right there.
It's sometimes
called the concept
of history, or process
history, or memory,
or something like that.
I think it would work well
with a semiconductor process,
but I know it works well
with injection molding,
because I'll show
you in a second.
Imagine I have an
injection molding process,
and I decide to
make these changes
by changing the hold time.
Every time I get an error,
I change the hold time.
So every time I cycle this
thing, which is pretty rapid,
I change the hold time.
Now, the hold time determines,
among other things,
the temperature at which
you open the mold--
how cool it is when it opens up,
when you release the pressure.
OK, how long do you
think it takes that mold
to reach equilibrium after
I change the hold time?
You think it reaches equilibrium
after the first cycle?
Big piece of metal--
I say, hold it an
extra 10 seconds
so it starts to cool off.
It's probably going to take
several of those cycles
before it cools off to its
new equilibrium temperature.
Does that makes sense?
And then, if I say, let's open
it quicker all of a sudden--
I open it quicker-- it's
going to start to heat up--
it's going to take a
while to heat up there.
So in fact, the process
is not at steady state.
At least the disturbances
are not at steady state.
There's a little bit of history.
And we can represent
this mathematically
by taking a purely random
independent sequence
and put it through a
first-order process,
and you end up with an
equation that shows, in fact,
the next disturbance is somewhat
predicted by the prior ones.
There's a little bit of
memory between the two,
and this is where we get
the concept of some process
correlation.
So what happens if there's
process correlation?
Well, this is a lot harder
to do theoretically,
so we did it in simulation.
I think we also have a
theoretical one on this,
but now look at-- here's
the variance ratio,
same thing as before, but
now with a disturbance
that has a little
bit of correlation.
Watch what happens.
As I increase the gain
from zero up to 1,
what happens to
the variance ratio?
It actually goes
down for a while.
I'm not sure these
numbers are right.
This one's not right.
That one's not right.
But anyway, it's going down.
Actually, I'm sorry.
That can be right.
There's another factor in here.
So why would the
variance ratio go down?
Well, it's because
I now actually do
get some information about what
the next disturbance is going
to be based on the prior one.
That's essentially
what correlation means.
And it's kind of
cool, because it
can't be much more specific than
that, but it basically says,
I can--
I'll show you this in a
moment, but I can actually
use this controller as a
way of measuring correlation
in the process.
If the variance ratio
goes down, there
had to have been
some correlation.
Here's the curve that
I was thinking of.
So you can think
of it instead as
sort of a continuum
of correlation.
Here's zero correlation, and
here's a large correlation,
if you will.
So zero correlation is
the first case we had--
independent random variable.
And here's that same
curve that we had before,
where, at 1, it
was still up there.
As I increase the amount of
correlation-- in other words,
as the words as the memory
gets stronger and stronger--
this curve starts
to come down here,
where at very large values,
you can see that at 1,
I could have a
variance ratio as low
as 1/3, which means
that, depending
on the physics of
the process, I could
take a broad shift
in distribution
and make it narrow and
centered with this approach.
And this is with exactly
the same controller, nothing
different.
So the cool thing is that
we end up with these--
it's actually a continuum,
but we can say that,
for a totally
uncorrelated process,
here's what's going to happen--
mean shift and
variance increase.
If we start to have some
correlation in the process,
and if there's some memory, some
reason that the disturbance is
occurring, we can start
to actually get both.
So who believes this?
It's just simulation.
It's just math.
Who believes it?
Come on.
Abstention's not allowed.
Believers?
AUDIENCE: I don't believe in
bending an injection molding.
[LAUGHS]
DAVID HARDT:
Believers, agnostics?
OK.
Obviously, it must work,
or I wouldn't say this.
So George Su, a good
part of his thesis
was to say that the theory
wasn't that-- in the end,
if you'd already
had the background,
the theory isn't that extensive.
And it does seem
too good to be true,
so we said, let's
do an experiment,
and let's try to
find two extremes.
Let's find something
that we think
has the least amount of
correlation and something
that has a reasonable
correlation.
Let's also find something that's
quick and easy to do in the lab
that we have.
And so we decided not
to do semiconductors.
We decided to do bending
an injection molding.
And so George set up this
experiment, which, in fact,
you guys in Singapore, when
you view this, will recognize,
because you've done this
in your summer experiments.
It's an experiment we
used to do in this class.
You take a simple strip of
sheet metal and you bend it.
The input is the
depth of the punch.
The output is the angle--
pretty simple.
And we're going to
do injection molding.
This is in George's thesis.
And here's the process
model for bending--
pretty simple, right?
The input is the
displacement of that punch.
The output is the angle.
George did a number of tests.
He put in different [INAUDIBLE].
He measured different angles--
shouldn't be the straight,
but he got some good results.
And so he came up with this
number for a particular value
of steel.
Now, keep in mind, this
number will change immediately
if I put different
thickness material in
or a different composition
material, because it
depends yield strengths,
and stiffness,
and that sort of thing.
But he got a nice
number for this.
So all he needed from
that was the slope.
Now he had that slope.
He could tune the loop
gain, knowing that slope
to be somewhere around
where we wanted it to be.
So he implemented that.
And this data's a
little bit weird,
because we hadn't, at this
point, done all the theory
and realized that there was
only one true controller.
So none of these are actually
for the best controller case.
So here's where
a controller that
is a proportional controller,
no integral control,
and has a gain of 1/7.
And what we want to look at
was the variance ratio only,
and then see-- indeed,
what we got is--
here's the data beforehand.
Here's the data after-hand.
And our variance did
go up, and it went up
roughly equal to what
we expected it to see.
That's not one of the good ones.
Yeah, so here was one of the
cooler things that we did.
This Is, now where we
did integral control.
And we put in a disturbance,
but the disturbance
was not a mean shift.
What we did is we took material
of exactly the same thickness--
I think that's what we did here.
Yeah, we did material
exactly the same thickness,
but a different material.
I think we put it in
aluminum, instead of steel.
So now the gain is wrong.
So right here,
everything's fine.
The target is 35 degrees.
And George slips in
a different material.
So immediately, the
angle goes right down,
because he's using the
setting from the prior cycle.
So now we've got
this huge error.
But what happens?
By following the algorithm,
in one, two, three, four time
steps, its back and right on
the money where it should be.
Now, he was using a game that
was too low, so this took
a long time to come back up.
And the variance ratio
was a little bit lower
than we would have
expected, but this
is another value
for this controller
that I wanted to point out
to, and why using higher gains
is important-- if something
like that came along,
different material or
significant changes
in the material.
This automatically,
with no intervention
on anybody's part-- not even
pulling the and on cord,
or having to do a statistically
significant number
of measurements-- just
get you back on track.
And it's a classic example of
the strength of disturbance
response for a controller.
Now, a compilation of
everything that George
did over all the experiments
with the integral controllers
is he just--
for the bending, he
said, let's take a look
at this quantity v, which was
the expected quality loss.
And he plotted it as a
function of the gain,
and indeed, it goes through a
minimum right at the gain of 1,
and then goes back up.
So that was a
pretty good result.
And it said that,
indeed, from no gain
at all where the
variance is very high
and the offsets could be very
high, we did a lot better.
AUDIENCE: Excuse me, was
that curve from experiments?
DAVID HARDT: Yes, yes.
Wait a second.
Actually, no, you're right.
I'm sorry.
This was calculated.
This was not from experiments.
Yeah.
But it suggested, again,
that kc should be 1.
Yes, I'm sorry.
So then he did this experiment.
He increased the gain to
1 for the material shift,
and-- well, this is a
different material shift too.
This was a change in thickness.
And, again change in thickness--
it immediately goes down,
and just in two time steps,
it's back up to zero--
so pretty cool.
So it confirms that, indeed,
we can go from here to here
in a predictable amount of time.
The higher the gain, the
faster it gets there.
But what this doesn't
show, but which
we did have with
other data-- it said,
yeah, it does
increase the variance
about the amount we expected.
OK, so now let's go
to injection molding.
Well, that got more
complicated right away,
because the first thing you
find out with injection molding
is you're not sure
which variables matter.
You're not sure what
the process gain is,
so we had to do a
full DOE on the thing
and do a significance, test and
find out what was important.
And what we ended up with,
through the end of analysis
and some other stuff was, I
think-- yeah, that hold time--
for his particular problem, hold
time was the most important.
He was molding rings,
simple test rings.
And so we came up with a
model that looked like this.
Again, that term didn't matter,
but it was a constant times
x2, which was the hold time.
This is reduced one.
He started with a lot more
variables to start with.
So here's proportional
control-- again,
one that we later abandoned.
But it gives you a nice example
of what-- of a bunch of things.
Here's open loop, and
he's making these parts
and noticing they're
all over the place,
and they're kind of drifting.
They're not even steady.
And then he turns on the
controller with a closed loop
gain of 1/2, and the mean
value is not correct,
but it's constant.
So it's completely
eliminating these shifts
that were going on, and the
effect is quite dramatic.
Oh, and the other thing
that's really cool
is that the variance
ratio was like 1/4.
So you can see here that this
is kind of all over the place,
and now it's greatly reduced.
You can actually measure
the correlation of these two
processes by just doing--
running it through a
correlation filter.
This doesn't tell you
just by looking at it,
they're using that
function, but this basically
means that bending was
indeed uncorrelated,
and injection molding
was-- had some correlation.
There's a little bit of
correlation in the bending,
because the variance
comes from coupons
that were cut from the
same sheet of sheet metal
and that sort of thing.
That's cool too.
That's basically more
of the same thing.
Here's the one I want to
show you is that in injection
molding integral control--
it just zooms right in.
The desired value was 1.436.
It just pops you
right onto that.
I guess the measurements
have some error in,
but this is in inches--
1.438, and a variance
ratio of 0.4.
So this is the one
example from his data
of implementing what we
consider the ideal controller.
Simply put, it does what
we expected it to do.
So from these model
predictions and the assumptions
that we make, we
make the argument
that we can do this discrete
time control stuff--
that discrete time
control theory
will well fit what's going on.
And you get this condition,
where you will always
center this, and you
will get varying degrees
of either amplification or
attenuation of the variance.
But the thing I
want to emphasize
is that this is hardcore
feedback control.
But the way we implement it,
the way it could be implemented
is simply to have a
path of paper that says,
if you measure this error,
do the following thing.
If you measure that error,
And you will get these results.
So it's highly implementable.
It could be done
automated as well,
but it's highly implementable.
And as I understand, in
the semiconductor field,
the run-by-run is--
I guess my sense was that,
when it first came out,
everybody said, yeah, that's
great, but we don't need it.
And now, as basically
the needs here
and the criticality
of the mean shifts
have gotten tighter and tighter,
they're saying, oh, jeez,
we do need this, and
it's starting to be used.
Is that correct?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
DAVID HARDT: Yeah.
I think we talked about
this earlier in the term.
This whole issue-- when you
get to process capability,
if the state of the art is--
here's the process, and here's
the process capability window,
show me the problem you have.
There's no problem.
But if this window all of a
sudden looks like this, say,
because you're doing 10th
micron lines, whereas before,
you were doing 5 micron lines,
or you're doing precision
machine, whereas before you
were doing non-precision--
this compared to this
looks pretty awful.
And if you don't know how
to go from here to here,
what do you do?
Well, again, run-by-run
or cycle-to-cycle
says, well, one thing I can
tell you is I can get that baby
right over in the middle there.
And if I can work on the
variance, I can do more.
And the other thing is
the correlation helps.
We've kind of
avoided correlation--
because it's
theoretically nasty--
throughout this class,
but most processes
do have a little bit
of correlation in them.
And if I have the
correlation, then indeed,
I can reduce this even
more, as I mentioned.
And the last thing I mentioned
is that we have demonstrated
this as well on a couple
different processes,
but Adam [INAUDIBLE],,
a couple of years ago,
extended it to a
100-by-100 problem--
so 100 inputs, 100
outputs-- because we
had this whole
process we've been
looking at in our lab for years
called flexible die-forming
forming.
And we had a tool, a
forming machine-- full-size
forming machine made
up of a lot of elements
you can move around.
And in this particular case,
there were 100 elements.
We used to have a lot
more, but he had 100.
And the idea is you would form
something, measure it, and say
there's a shape error.
How do I fix it?
And you'd like to do that
as quickly as possible.
And with this method,
you could show
that, within one
or two cycles, you
could reduce the error in that.
The extension is pretty
complicated, but most
of the results just to
show up the same way.
OK?
Labor Day well spent--
all right, if you're interested
in this more, as I said,
there are a couple of papers
that I put on the web.
There are two
underlying theses--
a master's thesis
and a PhD thesis.
That's just the work
we've done here.
And then, of course, in the
semiconductor literature
primarily-- a little bit
in the statistical control
literature-- there's
more into this idea
of run-by-run control.
And let's hear the
term they use, Duane?
It's in the--
AUDIENCE: There's
run-to-run, run-by-run--
DAVID HARDT: Yeah, run-to-run--
but even in the general
statistics community,
there is a term for--
oh, they call it
adjustment, something
like continuous adjustment
or feedback adjustment.
AUDIENCE:
--engineering control--
DAVID HARDT: Yeah,
engineering control-- yeah.
It's used a little
bit derogatorily.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DAVID HARDT: Yeah--
right, right.
So yeah, if you have to have
any more questions about that,
feel free to contact me.
OK, thank you all.